convolution neural network tutorial my
name is Richard Kirchner with the simply
learned team that's w w simply learn
comm get it certified get ahead today
we're going to be covering the
convolutional neural network tutorial do
you know how deep learning recognizes
the objects in an image and really this
particular neural network is how image
recognition works is very central one of
the biggest building blocks for image
recognition it does it using convolution
neural network and we over here we have
the basic picture of a hummingbird
pixels of an image fed as input you have
your input layer coming in so it takes
that graphic and puts it into the input
layer you have all your hidden layers
and then you have your output layer and
your output layer one of those that's
gonna light up and say oh it's a bird
we're gonna go into depth we're gonna
actually go back and forth on this a
number of times today so if you're not
catching all the image don't worry we're
gonna get into the details so we have
our input layer accepts the pixels of
the image as input in the form of arrays
and you can see up here where they've
actually labeled each block of the bird
in different arrays so we'll dive into
deep as to how that looks like and how
those matrixes are set up your hidden
layer carry out feature extraction by
performing certain calculations and
manipulation so this is the part that
kind of reorganizes that picture
multiple ways until we get some data
that's easy to read for the neural
network this layer uses a matrix filter
and performs convolution operation to
detect patterns in the image and if you
remember that convolution means to coil
or to twist so we're gonna twist the
data around and alter it and use that
operation to detect a new pattern there
are multiple hidden layers like
convolution layer rel u is how that is
pronounced when that's the rectified
linear unit that has to do with the
activation function that's used pooling
layer also uses multiple filters to
detect edges corners eyes feathers beak
etc just like the term says pooling is
pulling information together we'll look
into that a lot closer here so if you're
if it's a little confusing now we'll dig
in deep and try to get you squared away
with that and then finally there is a
full
connected layer that identifies the
object in the image so we have these
different layers coming through in the
hidden layers and they come into the
final area and that's where we have the
one node or one neural network entity
that lights up this says it's a bird
what's in it for you we're going to
cover an introduction to the CN n what
is convolution neural network how CN n
recognizes images we're gonna dig deeper
into that and really look at the
individual layers in the convolutional
neural network and finally we do a use
case implementation using the CN n well
begin our introduction to the CN n man
received a pioneer of convolutional
neural network Yann Lee kun-hee was a
director of face book AI research group
built the first convolutional neural
network called Linette in 1988 so these
have been around for a while and have
had a chance to mature over the years it
was used for character recognition tasks
like reading zip code digits imagine
processing mail and automating that
process CN n is a feed-forward neural
network that is generally used to
analyze visual images by producing data
with a grid like topology a CN n is also
known as a con vennett
and very key to this is we are looking
at images that was what this was
designed for and you'll see the
different layers as we dig in me or some
of the other some of them are actually
now used since we're using tensor flow
and chorus and our code later on you'll
see that some of those layers appear in
a lot of your other neural network
frameworks but in this case this is very
central to processing images and doing
so in a variety that captures multiple
images and really drills down into their
different features in this example here
you see flowers of two varieties orchid
and a rose I think the orchid is much
more dainty and beautiful and the Rose
smells quite beautiful have a couple
rose bushes in my yard they go into the
input layer that data is in sent to all
the different nodes in the next layer
one of the hidden layers based on its
different weights and it's set up it
then comes out and gives those a new
value those values then are multiplied
by their weights and go to the next
hidden layer and so on and then you have
the output layer and one of those notes
comes out and says it's an orchid and
the other one comes out and says it's a
rose depending on how was well it was
trained what separates the CNN or the
convolutional
network from other neural networks is a
convolutional operation forms the basis
of any convolutional neural network in a
CNN every M image is represented in the
form of arrays of pixel values so here
we have a real image of the digit 8 that
then gets put on to its pixel values
represented in the form of an array in
this case you have a 2 dimensional array
and then you can see in the final in
form we transform the digit 8 into its
representational form of pixels of zeros
and one where the ones represent in this
case the black part of the 8 and the
zeros represent the white background to
understand the convolution neural
network or how that convolutional
operation works we're gonna take a
sidestep and look at matrixes in this
case we're gonna simplify it we're gonna
take two matrices a and B of one
dimension now kind of separate this from
your thinking as we learned that you
want to focus just on the matrix aspect
of this and then we'll bring that back
together and see what that looks like
when we put the pieces for the
convolutional operation here we've set
up two arrays we have in this case or a
single dimension matrix and we have a
equals five three seven five nine seven
and we have B equals one two three so in
the convolution as it comes in there can
look at these two and we're gonna start
by doing multiplying them a times B and
so we multiply the arrays element wise
and we get 5 6 6 where 5 is the 5 times
1 6 is 3 times 2 and then the other 6 is
2 times 3 and since the two arrays
aren't the same size they're not the
same set up we're gonna just truncate
the first one and we're gonna look at
the second array multiplied just by the
first three elements of the first array
now that one's gonna be a little
confusing remember a computer gets to
repeat these processes hundreds of times
so we're not gonna just forget those
other numbers later on we'll see we'll
bring those back in and then we have
this sum of the product in this case 5
plus 6 plus 6 equals 17 so in our a
times B our very first digit in that
matrix of a times B is 17 and if you
remember I said we're not going to
forget the other digits so we now have 3
to 5 we move one set over and we take 3
to 5
and we multiply that times B and you'll
see that 3 times 1 is 3 2 times 2 is 4
and so on and so on we sum it up so now
we have the second digit of our a times
B product in the matrix and we continue
on with that same thing so on and so on
so then we would go from 3 75275 9 to 5
97 this short matrix that we have for a
we've now covered all the different
entities and a that matched three
different levels of B now in a little
bit we're gonna cover where we use this
math this multiplying a matrix is and
how that works but it's important to
understand that we're going through the
matrix of multiplying the different
parts to it to match the smaller matrix
with the larger matrix I know a lot of
people get lost out is we know what's
going on here with these matrixes Oh
scary math not really that scary when
you break it down we're looking at a
section of a and we're comparing it to B
so when you break that down your mind
like that you realize okay so I'm just
taking these two matrixes and comparing
them and I'm bringing the value down
into one matrix a times B we're doing
that information in a way that will help
the computer see different aspects let's
go ahead and flip over again back to our
images images time I going to the most
basic two-dimensional image you can get
to consider the following two images the
image for the symbol backslash when you
press the backslash the above image is
processed and you can see therefore the
image for the forward slash is the
opposite so we click the forward slash
button that flips very basic we have
four pixels going in can't get any more
basic than that here we have a little
bit more complicated picture we take a
real image of a smiley face then we
represent that in the form of black and
white pixels so if this was an image in
the computer its black and white and
like we saw before we convert this into
the zeros and one so where the other one
would have just been a matrix of just
four dots now we have a significantly
larger image coming in so don't worry
we're gonna bring this all together here
in just a little bit layers in
convolutional neural network we're
looking at this we have our convolution
layer and that really is the central
aspect of processing images in the
evolution oral network that's why we
have it and then that's going to be
feeding in and you have your relative
you layer which is you know we talked
about the rectified linear unit I'll
talk about that a little bit later the
rel U is and how it act is how that
layers activated is the math behind it
what makes a neurons fire you'll see
that a lot of other neural networks when
you're using it just by itself is for
processing smaller amounts of data where
you use the atom activation feature for
large data coming in now because we're
processing small amounts of data and you
can achieve a or works great you have
you're pooling layer that's where you're
pulling the data together pooling is a
neural network term it's very commonly
used I like to use a term reduce so if
you're coming from the map and reduce
side you'll see that we're mapping all
this data through all these networks and
then we're gonna reduce it we're gonna
pull it together and then finally we
have the fully connected layer that's
where our outputs gonna come out so we
have started to look at matrixes we've
started to look at the convolutional
layer and where it fits in and
everything we've taken a look at images
so we're gonna focus more on the
convolution layer since this is a
convolutional neural network a
convolution layer has a number of
filters and perform convolution
operation every image is considered as a
matrix of pixels consider the following
five by five image whose pixel values
are only zero and one now obviously when
we're dealing with color there's all
kinds of things that come in on color
processing but we want to keep it simple
and just keep it black and white and so
we have our image pixels so we're
sliding the filter matrix over the image
and computing the dot product to detect
the patterns right here you can ask
where does this filter come from this is
a bit confusing because the filter is
going to be derived later on we build
the filters when we program or train our
model so you don't need to worry what
the filter actually is but you do need
to understand how a convolution layer
works is what is the filter doing filter
and you'll have mini filters you don't
have just one filter you'll have lots of
filters that are gonna look for
different aspects and so the filter
might be looking for just edges it might
be looking for different parts we'll
cover that little bit more detail in a
minute
right now we're just focusing
how the filter works as a matrix
remember earlier we talked about
multiplying matrixes together and here
we have our two-dimensional matrix and
you can see we take the filter and we
multiply it in the upper left image and
you can see right here 1 times 1 1 times
0 1 times 1 we multiply those all
together than sum them and we end up
with the convolve feature of 4 I'm gonna
take that and sliding the filter matrix
over the image and computing the dot
product to detect patterns so we're just
going to slide this so we're gonna
predict the first one and just slide it
over 1 knotch
predict the second one and so on and so
on all the way through until we have a
new matrix and this matrix which is the
same size as the filter has reduced the
image and whatever filter whatever
that's filtering out is gonna be looking
at just those features reduced down to a
smaller matrix
so once the feature maps are extracted
the next step is to move them to the rel
you layer so the rel you layer the next
step first is going to perform an
element-wise operation so each of those
maps coming in if there's negative
pixels so it says all the negative
pixels to 0 and you can see this nice
graph where just zeros out the negatives
and then you have a value that goes from
0 up to whatever value is coming out of
the matrix this introduces non-linearity
to the network so up until now we have a
we say linearity we're talking about the
fact that the feature has a value so
it's a linear feature this feature came
up and has let's say the feature is the
edge of the beak it's like or the
backslash that we saw look at that and
say ok this feature has a value from
negative 10 to 10 in this case if it was
1 and say yeah this might be a beak it
might not might be an edge right there
minus 5 means no we're not even gonna
look at it to 0 and so we end up with an
output and the output takes all these
features all these filtered features
remember we're not just running one
filter on this we're running a number of
filters on this image and so we end up
with an rectified feature map that is
looking at just the features coming
through and how they weigh in from our
filters so here we have an input of a
looks like
to convert very exotic looking real
images scanned in multiple convolution
and the rel you layers for locating
features and you can see up here is turn
it into a black and white image and in
this case we're looking in the upper
right hand corner for a feature and that
box scans over a lot of times it doesn't
scan one pixel at a time a lot of times
it will skip by two or three or four
pixels to speed up the process that's
one of the ways you can compensate if
you don't have enough resources on your
computation for large images and it's
not just one filter slowly goes across
the image you have multiple filters have
been programmed in there so you're
looking at a lot of different filters
going over the different aspects of the
image and just lighting across there and
forming a new matrix one more aspect to
note about the rel you layer is we're
not just having one rel you coming in so
not only do we have multiple features
going through but we're generating
multiple rel you layers for locating the
features it's very important to note you
know so we have a quite a bundle we have
multiple filters multiple raelia which
brings us to the next step forward
propagation now we're going to look at
the pooling layer the rectified feature
map now goes through a pooling layer
pooling is a down sampling operation
that reduces the dimensionality of the
feature map that's all we're trying to
do we're trying to take a huge amount of
information and reduce it down to single
answer this is a specific kind of bird
this is an iris this is a rose so you
have a rectified feature map you see
here we have a rectified feature map
coming in we set the max pooling with a
two by two filters and a stride of two
and if you remember correctly I talked
about not going one pixel at a time well
that's where the stride comes in we end
up with a two by two pooled feature map
but instead of moving one over each time
and looking at every possible
combination we skip a stitch skip a few
there we go by two we skip every other
pixel we just do every other one and
this reduces our rectified feature map
which as you can see over here sixteen
by sixteen to a four by four so we're
continually trying to filter and reduce
our data so that we can get to something
we can manage and over here you see that
we have the map
three four one and two and in the max
pooling we're looking for the max value
a little bit different than what we were
looking at before so coming from the
rectified feature we're now finding the
max value and then we're pooling those
features together so instead of think of
this as image of the map think of this
as how valuable is a feature in that
area how much of a feature value do we
have we just want to find the best or
the maximum feature for that area they
might have that one piece of the filter
of the beak set up I see a 1 in this
beak in this image and then it skips
over says I see a 3 in this image and it
says oh this one is rated as a 4 we
don't want to sum it together because in
you know you might have like five ones
and I'll say uh five but you might have
four zeros and one ten and that ten says
well this is definitely a beak where the
ones will say probably not a be a little
strange analogy since we're looking at a
bird but you can see how that pooled
feature map comes down and we're just
looking for the max value in each one of
those matrixes pooling layer uses
different filters to identify different
parts of the image like edges corners
body feathers eyes beak etc I know I
focused mainly on the beak but obviously
each feature could be each a different
part of the bird coming in so let's take
a look at what that looks like structure
of a convolution neural network so far
this is where we're at right now we have
our input image coming in and then we
use our filters and there's multiple
filters on there that are being
developed to kind of twist and change
that data and so we multiply the matrix
is we take that little filter maybe it's
a two by two we multiply it by each
piece of the image and if we step two
then it's every other piece of the image
that generates multiple convolution
layers so we have a number of
convolution layers we have set up in
there just looking at that data we then
take those convolution layers we run
them through the rel you set up and then
once we've done through the rel you set
up and we have multiple rel yous going
on multiple layers that are rel you then
we're gonna take those multiple layers
and we're gonna be pooling them so now
we have the pooling layers or multiple
pooling is going on up until this point
we're dealing with sometimes it's
multiple dimension so you can have three
dimensions some strange data setups that
aren't doing images but looking at
things they can have four or five six
seven dimensions so right now we're
looking at 2d image dimensions coming in
into the pooling layer so the next step
is we want to reduce those dimensions or
flatten them so flattening flattening is
a process of converting all of the
results in two-dimensional arrays from
pooled feature map into a single long
continuous linear vector so over here
you see where we have a pooled feature
map maybe that's the bird wing and it
has values six eight four seven and we
want to just flatten this out and turn
it into six eight four seven or a single
linear vector and we find out that not
only do do each of the pooled feature
maps we do all of them into one long
linear vector so now we've gone through
our convolutional neural network part
and we have the input layer into the
next set up all we've done is taken all
those different pooling layers and we
flatten them out and combine them into a
single linear vector going in so after
we've done the flattening we have just a
quick recap because we've covered so
much so it's important to go back and
take a look at each of the steps we've
gone through the structure of the
network's so far we have our convolution
where we twist it and we filter it
multiply the matrixes we end up with our
convolutional layer which uses the rel
you to figure out the values going out
into the pooling as you have numerous
convolution layers that then create
numerous pooling layers pooling that
data together which is the max value
which one we want to send forward we
want to send the best value and then
we're going to take all of that from
each of the pooling layers and we're
going to flatten it and we're gonna
combine them into a single input going
into the final layer once you get to
that step you might be looking at that
going boy that looks like the normal
into it to most neural network and
you're correct it is so once we have the
flattened matrix from the pooling layer
that becomes our input so the pooling
layer is fed as an input to the fully
connected layer to classify the image
and so you can see as our flatten matrix
comes in in this case we have the pixels
from the flattened matrix fed as an
input back to our toucan or whatever
that kind of bird that is I need one of
these to identify what kind of bird that
is it comes into our forward propagation
network and that will then have the
different weights coming down across
and then finally it selects that that's
a bird and that is not a dog or a cat in
this case even though it's not labeled
the final layer there in red is our
output layer our final output layer this
is bird cat or dog so quick recap of
everything we've covered so far we have
our input image which is twisted and
multiplied the filters are multiplied
times the maître and the to matrix is
multiplied all the filters to create our
convolution layer our convolution layers
there's multiple layers in there because
it's all building multiple layers off
the different filters that goes through
the rel you this activation and that
creates our pooling and so once we get
into the pooling layer we then and the
pooling look for who's the best with
some max value coming in from our
convolution and then we take that layer
and we flatten it and then it goes into
a fully connected layer our fully
connected neural network and then to the
output and here we can see the entire
process how the CNN recognizes a bird
this is kind of nice because of showing
the little pixels and where they're
going you can see the filter is
generating this convolution Network and
that filter shows up in the bottom part
of the convolution Network and then
based on that it uses the real ood for
the pooling the pooling then find out
which one's the best and so on all the
way to the fully connected layer at the
end or the classification and the output
layer so they'd be a classification
neural network at the end so we covered
a lot of theory up till now and you can
imagine each one of these steps has to
be broken down in code so putting that
together can be a little complicated not
that each step of the process is overly
complicated but because we have so many
steps we have one two three four five
different steps going on here with some
steps in there we're gonna break that
down and walk through that in code so in
our use case implementation using the
CNN we'll be using the CFR ten data set
from Canadian Institute for Advanced
Research for classifying images across
ten categories unfortunately they don't
let me know whether it's gonna be a
toucan or some other kind of bird but we
do get to find out whether it can
categorize between a ship a frog deer
bird airplane automobile cat dog horse
truck so that's a lot of fun and
if you're looking anything in the news
at all of our automated cars and
everything else you can see where this
kind of processing is so important in
today's world and very cutting edge as
far as what's coming out in the
commercial deployment I mean this is
really cool stuff we're starting to see
this just about everywhere in industry
so a great time to be playing with this
and figuring it all out let's go ahead
and dive into the code and see what that
looks like when we're actually writing
our script before we go on let's do one
more quick look at what we have here
let's just take a look at data batch one
keys and remember Jupiter notebook I can
get by with not doing the print
statement if I put a variable down there
it'll just display the variable and you
can see in our data batch one for the
keys since this is a dictionary we have
the batch one label data and file names
so you can actually see how it's broken
up in our data set so for the next step
or step four is we're calling it we want
to display the image using Matt plot
library there's many ways to display the
images you can even those other ways to
drill into it but Matt plot library is
really good for this and we'll also look
at our first reshape set up or shaping
the data so you can have a little
glimpse into what that means so we're
going to start by importing our map plot
and of course since I am doing Jupiter
notebook I need to do the map plot in
line command so it shows up on my page
so here we go we're going to import map
plot library type lot as PLT and if you
remember mat plot library the pie plot
is like a canvas that we paint stuff on
- and there's my percentage sign map
plot library in line so it's gonna show
up in my notebook and then of course
we're gonna import numpy as NP for our
numbers Python array setup and let's go
ahead and set x equals to data batch one
so this will pull in all the data going
into the x value and then because this
is just a long stream of binary data we
need to go a little bit of reshaping so
in here we have to go ahead and reshape
the data we have 10,000 images okay that
looks correct and this is kind of an
interesting thing it took me a little
bit - I had to go research this myself
to figure out what's going on with this
data and what it is is it's a 32 by
to picture let me do this go ahead
drawing pad on here so we have 32 bits
by 32 bits and it's in color so there's
three bits of color now I don't know why
the data is particularly like this it
probably has to do with how they
originally encoded it but most pictures
put the three afterward so what we're
doing here is we're gonna take the shape
we're gonna take the data which is just
a long stream of information and we're
gonna break it up into 10,000 pieces and
those 10,000 pieces then are broken into
three pieces each and those three pieces
that are 32 by 32 you can look at this
like an old-fashioned projector where
they have the red screen or the red
projector of the blue projector and the
green projector and they add them all
together and each one of those is a 32
by 32 bit so that's probably how this
was originally formatted within that
kind of idea things have changed so
we're going to transpose it and we're
going to take the 3 which was here and
we're gonna put it at the end so the
first part is reshaping the data from a
single line of bit data or whatever
format it is into 10,000 by 3 by 32 by
32 and then we're going to transpose the
color factor to the last place so it's
the image then the 32 by 32 in the
middle that's this part right here and
then finally we're going to take this
which is 3 bits of data and put it at
the end so it's more like we do process
images now and then as type this is
really important that we're going to use
in integer 8 you can come in here and
you'll see a lot of these they'll try to
do this with a float or float 64 which
you got to remember though is a float
uses a lot of memory so once you switch
this into something that's not integer 8
which is goes up to 128 you are just
going to the the amount of RAM let's
just put that in here it's gonna go way
up the amount of RAM that it loads so
you want to go ahead and use this you
can try the other ones and see what
happens if you have a lot of RAM on your
computer but for this exercise this will
work just fine and let's go ahead and
take that and run this so now our X
variable is all loaded and it has all
the images in it
the batch one data batch one and just to
show we are talking about with the as
type on there if we go ahead and take X
zero and just look for its max value let
me go ahead and run that you'll see it
doesn't poop sai-san 128 is 255 you'll
see doesn't go over 255 because it's an
basically an ASCII character is what
we're keeping that down - we're keeping
those values down so they're only 255 0
to 255 versus float value which would
bring this up exponentially in size and
since we're using the mat plot library
we can do oops it's not what I wanted
since we're using the mat plot library
we can take our canvas and just do a PLT
dot I am for image show and let's just
take a look at what X 0 looks like and
it comes in I'm not sure what that is
but you can see it's a very low grade
image broken down to the minimal pixels
on there and if we did the same thing oh
let's do let's see what one looks like
hopefully it's a little easier to see
run on there not enter
let's hit the run on that and we can see
this is probably a semi-truck that's a
good guess on there and I can just go
back up here instead of typing the same
line in over and over we'll look at
three that looks like a dump truck
unloading and so on you can do any of
the 10,000 images you can just jump to
55 looks like some kind of animal
looking at us there probably a dog just
for fun let's do just one more run on
there and we can see a nice car for our
image number 4 so you can see we pasted
through all the different images it's
very easy to look at them and they've
been reshaped to fit our view in what
the map plot library uses for its format
so the next step is we're going to start
creating some helper functions we'll
start by a 1 hot encoder to help us or
processing the data remember that your
labels they can't just be words they
have to switch it and we use the one hot
encoder to do that and then we'll also
create a class C far helper so it's
gonna have an init and a setup for the
images and then finally we'll go ahead
and run that code so you can see what
that looks like and then we get into the
fun part where we're actually going to
start creating our model our actual
neural network model so let's start by
creating our
hot encoder we're gonna create our own
here I'm just gonna return an out we'll
have our vector coming in and our value
is equal ten what this means is that we
have the ten values at 10 possible
labels and remember we don't look at the
labels as a number because a car isn't
one more than a horse
have you just kind of bizarre to have
horse equals zero card equals 1 plane
equals 2 cat equals 3 so a cat plus AK
articles what so instead we create a
numpy array of zeros and there's gonna
be 10 values so we have a 10 different
values in there so you have 0 or 1 1
means it's a cat
0 means it's not a cat in the next line
it might be that one means it's a car 0
means it's not a car so instead of
having one output with a value of 0 to
10 you have 10 outputs with the values
of 0 to 1 that's what the one hot
encoder is doing here and we're gonna
utilize this in code in just a minute so
let's go ahead and take a look at the
next helpers we have a few of these
helper functions we're gonna build and
when you're working with a very
complicated Python project dividing it
up into separate definitions and classes
is very important otherwise it just
becomes really ungainly to work with so
let's go ahead and put it in our next
helper which is a class and this is a
lot in this class so we'll break it down
here and let's just start a bit of space
right in there there we go now this a
little bit more readable at a second
space so we're gonna create our class
the cipher helper and we'll start by
initializing it now there's a lot going
on in here so let's start with the knit
part self dot I equals 0 they'll come in
and a little bit we'll come back to that
in the lower part we want to initialize
our training batches so when we went
through this there was like a meta batch
we don't need the meta batch but we do
need the data batch 1 2 3 4 5 and we do
not want the testing batch in here this
is just the self all trained batches so
we're going to make an array of all
those different images and then of
course we lift the test batch out so we
have our self dot test batch we're going
to initialize the training images and
the training labels and also the test
images and the
labels so these are just this is just to
initialize these variables in here then
we create another definition down here
and this is going to set up the images
let's just take a look and see what's
going on in there
now we could have all just put this as
part of the init part since this is all
just helper stuff but breaking it up
again makes it easier to read
it also makes it easier when we start
executing the different pieces to see
what's going on so that way we have a
nice print statement to say hey we're
now running this and this is what's
going on in here
we're gonna set up these self-training
images at this point and that's going to
go to a numpy array v stack and in there
we're gonna load up in this case the
data for D and self all train batches
again that points right up to here so
we're gonna go through each one of these
files or each one of these data sets
they're not a file anymore we've brought
them in data batch one points to the
actual data and so our self training
images is going to stack them all into R
into a number array and then it's always
nice to get the training length and
that's just a total number of self
training images in there and then we're
gonna take the self training images let
me switch marker colors because I am
getting a little too too much on the
markers up here whoops there we go bring
down our marker change so we can see it
a little better and at this point this
should look familiar where did we see
this well we wanted to look at this
above and we want to look at the images
in the mat plot library we had to
reshape it so we're doing the same thing
here we're taking our self training
images and based on the training length
total number of images because we
stacked them all together so now it's
just one large file of images we're
gonna take and look at it as our three
video cameras that are each displaying a
32 by 32 we're gonna switch that around
so that now we have each of our images
that stays the same place and then we
have our 32 by 32 and then by our 3 our
last our 3 different values for the
color and of course we want to go ahead
and they run this where we say divided
by 255 that was from earlier it just
brings all the data into
zero to one that's what this is doing so
we're turning this into a zero to one
array which is all the pictures 32 by 32
by 3 and then we're going to take the
self training labels and we're going to
pump those through our one hot encoder
we just made and we're gonna stack them
together and again we're converting this
into an array that goes from instead of
having horse equals 1 dog equals two and
then horse plus dog would equal 3 which
would be cat now it's going to be you
know an array of ten where each one is
zero to one then we want to go ahead and
set up our test images and labels and
when we're doing this you're gonna see
it's the same thing we just did with the
rest of them we just change colors right
here this is no different than what we
were doing up here with our training set
we're going to stack the different
images we're going to get the lengths of
them so we know how many images are in
there you certainly could add them by
hand which is nice to let the computer
do it especially if it ever changes on
the other end and you're using other
data and again we reshape them and
transpose them and we also do the one
hot encoder same thing we just did on
our training images so now our test
images are in the same format so now we
have a definition which sets up all our
images in there and then the next step
is to go ahead and batch a more next
batch and let's do another break out
here for batches because this is really
important to understand tis to throw me
for a little loop when I'm working with
tensorflow or chorus or a lot of these
we have our data coming in if you
remember we had like 10,000 photos let
me just put 10,000 down here we don't
want to run all 10,000 at once so we
want to break this up into batch sizes
and you also remember that we had the
number of photos in this case length of
test or whatever number is in there we
also have 32 by 32 by 3 so when we're
looking at the batch size we want to
change this from 10,000 to a batch of in
this case I think we're gonna do batches
of a hundred so we want to look at just
100 the first hundred of the photos and
if you remember we set self I equal to 0
so what we're looking at here is we're
going to create X we're gonna get the
next
from the very initialize we've already
initialized it for zero so we're going
to look at x from zero to batch size
which we've set to 100 so just the first
hundred images and then we're going to
reshape that into and this is important
to let the data know that we're looking
at 100 by 32 by 32 by 3
now we've already formatted it to the 32
by 32 by 3 this just sets everything up
correctly so that X has the data in
there in the correct order and the
correct shape and then the Y just like
the X is our labels so our training
labels again they go from 0 to that size
in this case they do self ID plus batch
size because the self is going to keep
changing and then finally we increment
this self I because we have 0 so we so
the next time we call it we're going to
get the next batch size and so basically
we have x + y X being the photograph
data coming in and Y being the label and
that of course is labeled through one
hot encoder so if you remember correctly
if it was a horse is equal to zero it
would be one for the zero position since
this is the horse and then everything
else would be 0 in here there we go
there's our array hard to see that array
so let's go ahead and take that and
we're gonna finish loading it since this
is our class and now we're armed with
all this our setup over here let's go
ahead and load that up and so we're
going to create a variable CH with the
CFR helper in it and then we're going to
do CH dot set up images now we could
have just put all the setup images under
the unit but by breaking this up into
two parts it makes it much more readable
and also if you're doing other work
there's reasons to do that as far as the
setup let's go ahead and run that and
you can see where it says setting up
training images and labels setting up
test images and that's one of the
reasons we broke it up is so that if
you're testing this out you can actually
have print statements and they're
telling you what's going on which is
really nice they did a good job with
this setup I like the way that it was
broken up in the back and then one quick
note you want to remember that batch to
set up the next batch was we have to run
a batch equals CH next batch of 100
because we're going to use the one
sighs but we'll come back to that we're
gonna use that just remember that that's
part of our code we're going to be using
it a minute from the definition we just
made so now we're ready to create our
model first thing we want to do is we
want to import our tensor flow as TF
I'll just go ahead and run that so it's
loaded up and you see we got a warning
here that's because they're making some
changes it's always growing and they're
gonna be depreciating one of the values
from float64 to float type or as treated
as an NP float64 nothing to really worry
about this doesn't even affect what
we're working on because we've said all
of our stuff to a 255 value or zero to
one and do keep in mind that zero to one
value that we converted the 255 is still
a float value but it'll easily work with
either the numpy float 64 or the numpy
d-type float it doesn't matter which one
it goes through so the depreciation
would not affect our code as we have it
and in our tensor flow we'll go ahead
and just increase the size in there just
a moment so you can get a better view of
the what we're typing in we're gonna set
a couple placeholders here and so we
have we're gonna set x equals TF
placeholder TF float 32 we just talked
about the float 64 versus the numpy
float we're actually just gonna keep
this at float 32 more than a significant
number decimal for what we're working
with and since it's a placeholder we're
gonna set the shape equal to and we've
set it equal to none because at this
point we're just holding the place on
there we'll be setting up as we run the
batches that's where the first value is
and then 32 by 32 by 3 that's what we
reshaped our data to fit in and then we
have our Y true equals placeholder TF
float 32 and the shape equals none comma
1010 is 210 different labels we have so
it's an array of ten and then let's
create one more placeholder we'll call
this a hold prob or hold probability and
we're gonna use this we don't have to
have a shape or anything for this this
placeholder is for what we call drop out
if you remember from our theory before
we drop out so many nodes is looking at
or the different values going through
which helps decrease bias so we need to
go ahead and put a placeholder for that
also and we'll run this so it's all
loaded up in there so we have our three
different placeholders
and since we're in tensorflow would you
use chorus it does some of this
automatically but we're in tensorflow
direct the Ross sits on tensorflow we're
going to go ahead and create some more
helper functions we're going to create
something to help us initialize the
weights initialize our bias if you
remember that each layer has to have a
bias going in we're gonna go ahead and
work on conversional 2d our max pool so
we have our pooling layer
our convolutional layer and then our
normal full layer so we're gonna go
ahead and put those all into definitions
and let's see what that looks like in
code and you can also grab some of these
and helper functions from the m in IST
the mist setup let me just put that in
there if you're under the tensorflow so
a lot of these are already in there but
we're going to go ahead and do our own
and we're gonna create our knit weights
and one of the reasons we're doing this
is so that you can actually start
thinking about what's going on in the
backend so even though there's ways to
do this with an automation sometimes
these have to be tweaked and you have to
put in your own setup in here now we're
not going to be doing that we're just
gonna recreate them for our code and
let's take a look at this we have our
weights and so what comes in is going to
be the shape and what comes out is going
to be random numbers so we're gonna go
ahead and just knit some random numbers
based on the shape with a standard
deviation of 0.1 kind of a fun way to do
that and then the TF variable in that
random distribution so we're just
creating a random distribution on there
that's all that is for the weights
now you might change that you may have a
higher standard deviation in some cases
you actually load preset weights that's
pretty rare usually you're testing that
against another model or something like
that and you want to see how those
weights configure with each other now
remember we have our bias so we need to
go ahead and initialize the bias with a
constant in this case we're using 0.1 a
lot of times the bias is just put in as
one and then you have your weights add
on to that but we're going to set this
as point 1 so we want to return a
convolutional to D in this case a neural
network this is would be a layer on here
what's going on with the con to D
because we're taking our data coming in
we're going to filter it strides if you
remember correctly strides came from
here's our image and then we only look
at this picture here and then maybe we
have a stride of
so we look at this picture here we
continue to look at the different
filters going on there the other thing
this does is that we have our data
coming in as 32 by 32 by 3 and we want
to change this so that it's just this is
three dimensions and it's going to
reformat this as just two dimensions so
it's going to take this number here and
combine it with the 32 by 32 so this is
a very important layer here because
reducing our data down using different
means and it connects down I'm just
gonna jump down one here it goes with
the convolutional layer so you have your
your kind of your pre formatting and the
set up and then you have your actual
convolution layer that goes through on
there
and you can see here we have an it
weights by the shape and knit bias shape
of three because we have the three
different here's our three again and
then we return the TF NN r lu with the
convention Trudy
so this convolutional has this feeding
into it right there it's using that as
part of it and of course the input is
the XY + B the bias so that's quite a
mouthful but these two or those are the
keys here to creating the convolutional
layers they're the convolutional 2d
coming in and then the convolutional
layer which then steps through and
creates all those filters we saw then of
course we have our pooling so after each
time we run it through the convectional
layer we want to pull the data if you
remember correctly on the on the pool
side and let me just get rid of all my
marks it's getting a little crazy there
and in fact let's go ahead and jump back
to that slide let's just take a look at
that slide over here so we have our
image coming in we create our
convolutional layer with all the filters
remember the filters go
you know the filter is coming in here
and it looks at these four boxes and
then if it's a step let's say step two
and then goes to these four boxes and
then the next step and so on
so we have our convolutional layer that
we generate or convolutional layers they
use the r lu function there's other
functions out there for this though the
r lu is the most the one that works the
best at least so far i'm sure that will
change then we have our pooling now if
you remember correctly the pooling was
max so if we had the filter coming in
and they did the multiplication on there
and we have a one and maybe a two here
and another one here and a 3 here 3 is
the max and so out of all of these you
then create an array that would be 3 and
if the max is over here 2 or whatever it
is that's what goes into the pooling
what's going on in our pooling so again
we're reducing that data down or
reducing it down as small as we can and
then finally we're gonna flatten it out
into a single array and that goes into
our fully connected layer and you can
see that here in the code right here
we're gonna create our normal full layer
so at some point we're going to take
from our pooling layer this will go into
some kind of flattening process and then
that'll be fed into the full the
different layers going in down here and
so we have our input size you'll see our
input layer get shape which is just
gonna get the shape for whatever's
coming in and then input size initial
weights is also based on the input layer
coming in and the input size down here
is based on the input layer shape so
we're just gonna Hardy use the shape and
I already have our size coming in and of
course you have to make sure you knit
the bias
I always put your bias on there and
we'll do that based on the size so this
will return TF mat mul input layer W
plus B this is just a normal full layer
that's what this means right down here
that's what we're gonna return so that
was a lot of steps we went through let's
go ahead and run that so those are all
loaded in there and let's go ahead and
create the layers let's see what that
looks like now that we've done all that
heavy lifting and everything we get to
do all the easy part let's go ahead and
create our layers will create a
convolution layer one and two two
different convolutional layers and then
we'll take that and we'll flatten that
out create a reshape pooling in there
for our reshape and then we'll have our
full layer at the end so let's start by
creating our first convolutional layer
then we come in here and let me just run
that real quick and I want you to notice
on here the 3 and the 32 this is
important because coming into this
convolutional layer we have three
different channels and 32 pixels each so
that has to be in there the 4 & 4 you
can play with
this is your filter size so if you
remember you have a filter and you have
your image and the filter slowly steps
over and filters out this image
depending on what your step is for this
particular setup for four is just fine
that should work pretty good for what
we're doing and for the size of the
image and then of course at the end once
you have your convolutional layer set up
you also need to pool it and you'll see
that the pooling is automatically set up
so that it would see the different shape
based on what's coming in so here we
have max to about two by two and we put
in the convolutional one that we just
created the convolutional layer we just
created goes right back into it and that
right up here as you can see is the X is
coming in from here so it knows to look
at the first model and set the the data
accordingly set that up so matches and
we went ahead and ran this already
I think and if we're going to do one
layer let's go ahead and do a second
layer down here yes we'll call it convo
- it's also a convolutional layer on
this and you'll see that we're feeding
convolutional one in the pooling so it
goes from convolutional one into
convolutional one pooling from
convolutional one pooling into
convolutional two and then from
convolutional two into convolutional two
pooling well go ahead and take this and
run this so these variables are all
loaded into memory and for flattened
layer let's go ahead and we'll do since
we have 64 coming out of here and we
have a four by four going in let's do
eight by eight by sixty-four so let's do
4096 this is gonna be the flat layer so
that's how many bits are coming through
and the flat layer and we'll reshape
this so we'll reshape our convo to
pooling and that will feed into here the
combo to pooling and then we're gonna
set it up as a single layer that's 4096
in size that's what that means there
we'll go ahead and run this so we've now
created this variable the convo to flat
and then we have our first full layer
this is the final neural network where
the flat layer going in and we're gonna
get and use the rail you for our set up
on there in a neural network for
evaluation then you'll notice that we're
going to create our first full layer our
normal full layer that's our definition
so we created that that's creating the
normal full layer and our input for the
data comes right here from the this goes
right into it the convo to flat so this
tells it how big the data is and we're
gonna have a come out it's going to have
1024 that's how big the layer is coming
out we'll go ahead and run this so now
we have our full layer 1 and with the
full layer 1 we I want to also define
the full one drop out to go with that so
our full everyone comes in key
probability equals whole probability
remember we created that earlier and the
full layer one is what's coming into it
and this is going backwards and training
the data we're not training every weight
we're only training a percentage of them
each time which helps get rid of the
bias so let me go ahead and run that and
finally we'll go ahead and create a why
predict which is gonna equal the normal
full one dropout and ten because we have
10 labels in there now in this neural
network we could have added additional
layers that would be another option to
play with you can also play with a set
of 1024 you can use other numbers for
the way that sets up on what's coming
out and going into the next one we're
only going to do just the one layer and
the one layer dropout and you can see if
we did another layer it'd be real easy
just to feed in the full one drop out
into full layer 2 and then full layer to
drop out would have full air to feed
into it and then you'd switch that here
for the Y prediction for right now this
is great this particular data set is
tried and true and we know that this
will work on it and if we just type in Y
predict and we run that we'll see that
this is a tensor object shape question
mark 10 D type 32 a quick way to double
check what we're working on so now we've
got all of our we've done a set up all
the way to the y predict which we just
did we want to go ahead and apply the
loss function and make sure that set up
in there create the optimizer and then
trainer optimizer and create a variable
to initialize all the global TF
variables so before we dive in to the
loss function let me point out one quick
thing we're just kind of a rehab over a
couple things and that is when we're
playing with this
setups we pointed out up here we can
change the 4/4 and use different numbers
there you change your outcome so
depending on what numbers you use here
we'll have a huge impact on how well
your model fits and that's the same here
of the 1024 also this is also another
number then if you continue to raise
that number you'll get possibly a better
fit you might over fit and if you lower
that number you'll use less resources
and generally you want to use this in
the exponential growth and exponential
being 2 for a 16 and in this case the
next one down would be 512 you can use
any number there but those would be the
ideal numbers when you look at this data
so the next step in all this is we need
to also create a way of tracking how
good our model is and we're going to
call this a loss function and so we're
going to create a cross entropy loss
function and so before we discuss
exactly what that is let's take a look
and see what we're feeding it we're
gonna feed it our labels and we have our
true labels and our prediction labels so
coming in here is where the two
different variables we're sending in or
the two different probability
distributions is one that we know is
true and what we think it's going to be
now this function right here when they
talk about cross entropy in information
theory the cross entropy between two
probability distributions over the same
underlying set of events measures the
average number of bits needed to
identify an event drawn from the set
that's a mouthful really we're just
looking at the amount of error in here
how many of these are correct and how
many of these are incorrect so how much
of it matches and we're going to look at
that we're just going to look at the
average that's what the mean reduced to
the mean means here so we're looking at
the average error on this and so the
next step is we're going to take the
error we want to know our cross entropy
or our loss function how much loss we
have that's going to be part of how we
train the model so when you know what
the loss is and we're training it you
feed that back into the backpropagation
setup and so we will go ahead and
optimize that here's our optimizer we're
gonna create the optimizer using an atom
optimizer remember there's a lot of
different ways of optimizing the data
atoms the most
popular used so our optimizer is gonna
equal the TF train Adam optimizer if you
don't remember what the learning rate is
let me just pop this back into here
here's our learning rate when you have
your weights you have all your weights
and your different nodes that are coming
out here's our node coming out it has
all its weights and then the error is
being propped sent back through in
Reverse on our neural network so we take
this error we adjust these weights based
on the different formulas in this case
the adam formula is what we're using we
don't want to just adjust them
completely we don't want to change this
weight so it exactly fits the data
coming through because if we made that
kind of adjustment it's going to be
biased to whatever the last data we sent
through is instead we're gonna multiply
that by 0.001 and make a very small
shift in this weight so our Delta W is
only 0.001 of the actual Delta W of the
full change we're going to compute from
the atom and then we want to go ahead
and train it so our training or setup a
training variable or function and this
is going to equal our optimizer minimize
cross entropy yeah we make sure we go
ahead and run this so it's loaded in
there and then we're almost ready to
train our model but before we do that we
need to create one more variable in here
and we're gonna create a variable to
initialize all the global TF variables
and look at this the TF global variable
initializer this is a tensorflow object
it goes through there and it looks at
all our different set up that we have
going under our tensor flow and then
initializes those variables so it's kind
of like a magic wand because it's all
hidden in the back end of tensorflow
all you need to know about this is that
you have to have the initialization on
there which is an operation and you have
to run that once you have your setup
going so we'll go ahead and run this
piece of code and then we're gonna go
ahead and train our data so let me run
this oh it's loaded up there and so now
we're gonna go ahead and run the model
by creating a graph session graph
session is a tensor flow term so you'll
see that coming up it's one of the
things that throws me because I always
think of graphics and spark and graph as
just general graphing but they talk
about a graph session so we're gonna go
ahead and run the model and let's go
ahead and
through this what's going on here and
let's pieces date in here and here we go
so we're gonna start off with it with a
TF session as sess so that's our actual
TF session we've created so we're right
here with the TF session our session
we're eating we're going to run TF
global variable initializer so right off
the bat we're initializing our variables
here and then we have 4 I and range 500
so what's going on here remember 500
we're going to break the data up and
we're gonna batch it in at 500 points
each we've created our session run so
we're gonna do with TF session as
session right here we've created our
variable session and then we're gonna
run and we're going to go ahead and
initialize it so we have our TF global
variables initializer that we created
that initializes our session in here the
next thing we're going to do is we're
gonna go for I in range of 500 batch
equals CH next batch so if you remember
correctly this is loading up a 100
pictures at a time and this is going to
loop through that 500 times so we are
literally doing what is that 500 times
100 is 50,000 so that's 50 thousand
pictures we're gonna process right there
in the first processes we're gonna do a
session run we're going to take our
train we created our train variable or
optimizer in there we're gonna feed it
the dictionary we had our feed
dictionary that you created and we have
x equals batch 0 coming in Y true batch
1 hold the probability 0.5 and then just
so that we can keep track of what's
going on we're gonna every hundred steps
we're gonna run a print so currently on
step format accuracy is and we're gonna
get matches equals TF dot equal to F
argument Y prediction 1 TF tar max Y
true comma 1 so we're going to look at
this is how many matches it has and here
are ACC all we're doing here is we're
going to take the matches how many
matches they have it creates it and
generates a chart we're going to convert
that to float that's what the TF cast
does and then we just want to know the
average we're just one of the average of
the
accuracy and then we'll go ahead and
print that out print session run
accuracy feed dictionary so it takes all
this and it prints out our accuracy on
there so let's go ahead and take this up
some screens there let's go ahead and
take this and let's run it and this is
gonna take a little bit to run so let's
see what happens on my old laptop and
we'll see here that we have our current
we're currently on step 0 it takes a
little bit to get through the accuracy
and this will take just a moment to run
we can see that on our step 0 it has an
accuracy of 0.1 or 0.1 o28 and as it's
running we'll go ahead you don't need to
watch it run all the way but this
accuracy is gonna change a little bit up
and down so we've actually lost some
accuracy during our step too but we'll
see how that comes out let's come back
after we run it all the way through and
see how the different steps come out
there's actually reading that backwards
the way this works is the closer we get
to 1 the more accuracy we have so you
can see here we've gone from a point 1
to a point three nine and we'll go ahead
and pause this and come back and see
what happens when we're done with the
full run all right now that we've
prepared the mill got it in the oven and
pull out my finished dish here if you've
ever watched any of the old cooking
shows let's discuss a little bit about
this accuracy going on here and how do
you interpret that we've done a couple
things first we've defined accuracy the
reason I got it backwards before is you
have loss or accuracy and with loss and
you'll get a graph that looks like this
it goes so if that's an ass by the way
there we go you get a graph that curves
down like this and with accuracy you get
a graph the curves up there's no good
it's doing now in this case one is
supposed to be really good accuracy that
means it gets close to one but it never
crosses one so if you have an accuracy
of one that is phenomenal
in fact that's pretty much I'm Paul
unheard-of and the same thing with loss
if you have a loss of zero that's also
unheard of zero is actually on this this
axis right here as we go in there so how
do we interpret that because you know if
I was looking at this and I go oh oh
point five one that's fifty one percent
you're doing fifty fifty no this is not
percentage let me just put that in there
it is
percentage this is log rhythmic what
that means is that point two is twice as
good as point one and we see point four
that's twice as good as point two real
way to convert this into a percentage
you really can't say this is a direct
percentage conversion what you can do
though is in your head if we were to
give this a percentage we might look at
this as 50% we're just guessing equals
0.1 and if 50% roughly equals 0.1 as we
started up here at the top remember at
the top here here's our point 102 eight
the accuracy of 50% then 75% is about
point two and so on and so on don't
quote those numbers because it doesn't
work that way they say that if you have
point nine five that's pretty much
saying a hundred percent and if you have
anywhere between you'd have to go look
this up we go and remove all my drawings
there so the magic number is 0.5 we
really want to be over a point five in
this whole thing and we have both 0.500
for members accuracy if we were looking
at loss then we would be looking the
other way but point O instead of how
high it is we went how low it is but
with accuracy being over a point five is
pretty valid that means this is pretty
solid and if you get to a point nine
five then it's a direct correlation
that's what we're looking for here in
these numbers you can see we finished
with this model at point five one three
five so still good and if we look at
when they ran this in the other end
remember there's a lot of randomness
that goes into it when we see the
weights they got point five two five one
so a little better than ours but that's
fine you'll find your own comes up a
little bit better or worse depending on
just that randomness and so we've gone
through the whole model we've created we
trained the model and we've also gone
through on every hundredth run to test
the model to see how accurate it is and
now that we have a solid running model
on an accuracy let's go ahead and take a
look at what we cover today we did cover
a lot because this is a very complicated
subject and it's not so much complicated
in in any individual step it just has a
lot of steps involved so today we
covered what is a convolutional neural
network and you can see we have the
pictures coming in to the input layer to
the hidden layers to the output layer
and then get arose we talked about the
very basics at the beginning and we
discussed how a CNN recognizes images
and very basics as we converted the
image into a pixel map of zeros and ones
then we dive it into layers in a
convolutional neural network and we had
our convolutional layer our fully
convected layer our rel u layer and our
pooling layer and we looked at pooling
layer it reduces the data down to a
smaller amount by finding the first
finds of matches and then it finds the
maximum value in that match we discussed
all the different layers in there we
went into the fully connected layer
which is your normal the neural networks
you're probably used to dealing with
when we're just building a forward
propagation neural network and we
connected them all together and you can
see here we took the bird we did our
extracting our feature extraction and
multiple hidden layers where we had our
convolution which then generated those
little individual filters and we had our
rel U and then we took the rayleigh we
max pooled those and we took all those
pooled values at the end so they've been
reduced to smaller mappings we've
reduced that and then we fed that into
the fully connected layer and then
finally we went into the use case
implementation using CN N and we walked
through a full demo on the coding on
there with that I want to thank you for
joining us today so thank you for more
information visit www.gfi.com/webmonitor
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here